here's an scp that'll give you a serious  case of the mondays  scp-3166 a disgusting monster also known  as gorfield it looks like a giant ratty  fursuit of the character garfield from  the popular jim davis comic strip of the  same name but the suit is made out of  real cat fur and its insights are made  from putrid human flesh lasagna that is  somehow a genetic match for jim davis  himself whenever the garfield franchise  isn't doing well financially or in its  public image this monster manifests and  begins stalking someone associated with  the brand if it catches them before the  scp foundation can intercept it'll  either beat them to death or force feed  them the lasagna from its own body until  they die the only way to distract the  beast is to leave some fresh lasagna of  your own laying around which the beast  will immediately take as bait